you got I'm sorry I want to go back to
the you got the script how you got a
script you came on set this guy saved
our ass is what happened director James
man it's great working with you yeah he
he literally got the script like two
minutes before yeah I gotta get back to
work but he got the script two minutes
before coming on set we had to cast him
last minute cuz somebody fell out and he
killed it he did a great job Gus I was
rehearsing as I was getting dressed with
that word Patrick I was rehearsing with
the lead actor as I was getting dressed
and he was like man you already know the
dialogue and I was like yeah I'm trying
to pick it up as i get dress and makeup
it was crazy they literally just do me
in there next they know i'm doing a
scene that's every actors dream and so
any bit i'm sorry you said six months
since you done straight out of Compton
i'm not i washed out a competent in
august 2014 so a year here yeah you
hadn't booked anything I hadn't booked
anything and and this came about just
like that and it was like this is your
moment your mommy yet so when you were
taking a lift over from wherever you
were staying huh what was going through
your mind were you nervous I'm know it
was a nervous effort at first I was
thinking like all right this product
Polly isn't nothing if somebody's just
gonna drop out and not show up I was
like but imma go cuz I'm an actor and I
love acting in the pay me so I'm gonna
go and when I got to the set I owe this
is the real deal yeah then I got below I
got the jitters and the butterflies but
then I thought about my coach bobby
chance which you guys probably seen her
work you guys probably know Bobby chance
she also told me just to be a barracuda
a barracuda whatever it is just pick it
up just go out there play have fun you
know don't let the dialogue or anything
distract you just just have fun and
that's what I did then I found out d
major was a fun character and I was like
oh this is a dream come true and it was
just a great great experience this past
two days that's interesting be a
barracuda so what what what is that
exactly you said just have fun but but
is there also an aggressive side to it
where you need to just attack thing yeah
you just got a tacit you gotta put your
teeth into it get a nice grip and hold
on tight and that's exactly what I did
with this row I just put my teeth in it
and held on tight
you